and Andrew's got some new reporting for
us here on the NewsHour Andrew talk to
us what do we know
yes quite a few lines coming in Peter
hostile airport at 10 kilometers outside
the capital uh it's actually now under
the control of the Russians that
information from the Ukrainian
presidential advisor they control that
airstrip now it's not far from the
capital we're now hearing unconfirmed
reports that paratroopers have landed uh
on that airstrip and there are reports
that the Ukrainian artillery is opening
fire and there's a battle going on right
now at that airstrip now there's also
information prior to this happening
there were reports on Twitter that's
illusion 76 planes these are large troop
carriers
um 18 of them flew from Russia a Russian
Air Base heading this way and it would
have appear quite possibly the the two
are interlinked that the paratroopers
were on board these planes we've looked
into what the capabilities of the
illusion 76
are and the capabilities apparently
something like 140 troops could be
carried on each of those aircraft 18 of
those aircrafts so that would be a quite
a fighting force also unconfirmed
reports of 20 helicopters Reddit in
Belarus ready for flying in whether
they're on their way or whether they're
already here full of Special Forces now
could this be an assault a ground
assault on the capital to try to take
control of government buildings to try
to take control of power here
effectively this independent state at
threat at every level militarily
politically and there is no one
physically here to help right now is
there a sense there Andrew that the
people of Kiev are heading into a night
of trepidation I guess is the best word
not knowing what is literally perhaps
probably possibly coming their way
well if it's only trepidation that would
be a relief it could be far worse than
that there is no doubt uh it is unclear
what is happening in many parts of the
country
um we've we've we've heard that in
hakive there's been particularly vicious
fighting uh there have been a number of
airstrikes and civilian deaths in
considerable numbers the total dead in
in this conflicts even after only
um what no more than 18 hours are going
to be really high who knows what's going
to happen next we're also hearing
another report here quite an important
one uh the Chernobyl uh former nuclear
plant
um is a large area in an area where the
Belarus Advance has taken place the
Belarus Russian deployment of armor
coming from the Belarus border there was
a fight outside the Chernobyl plant this
was obviously the the the nuclear plant
where you have the meltdown that
disaster that tragedy that disaster back
in
2016 93 1996 what am I talking about
um the uh that that area has been an
area of conflict uh for several hours
but now we're hearing that the Russians
have gained control of the former
Chernobyl plant that entire area which
many parts of it are still Radioactive
in some in terms of the number of
casualties we can't give you an accurate
figure
um President lilinsky linensky should I
say has made it quite clear that martial
law is imposed now he's appeal for calm
he's also allowed all civilians to carry
firearms without any permits he's
basically telling people to defend
themselves if they have to here it's
very eerie and quiet if it's true about
these paratroopers and if it's true
about the Special Forces then fighting
is expected on the streets however in in
in a smaller amount of fighting than it
would be if the armored columns came all
the way here from the Belarus the road
from Belarus and other other areas as
well so yes the situation right now is
not just tense it's it's absolutely
charged with fear one does Andrew get
the sense from certainly some of the
military type analysts we've been
talking to here on the channel in the
past few hours that Mr zelinski is
playing this step by step as well as
anyone could play it if they were doing
his job despite on his part a lack of
you know political or military a
political or a military background is it
your sense that he's listening and
listening to the right advisors
it's hard to tell I I think zorensky
zielinski has done
um really quite all he can do under the
circumstances uh with the support he's
had however there is there is a feeling
on board in some places that perhaps he
pushed too hard against the intelligence
that there was going to be a full-scale
in Invasion and and of course many
ukrainians really became slightly
complacent about the prospect of the
capital coming under attack and all
major cities seaports to Land Air and
sea and from every direction attacks
have come and as far as the the security
forces are concerned they've been really
really stretched despite the last
minutes uh announcement to bring in
voluntary reservists that's only now
just just over 24 hours old you know 18
to 60 years of age at some are saying
that that could have happened a lot
earlier and with a full mobilizer Nation
for example the the Border we were
visiting uh only on Wednesday uh the
Belarus Russia and uh Ukraine border a a
three-way border we we were there we
inspected we we looked around and the
defenses were minimal I mean it was just
some razor wire and some not even
trenches the tanks went rolled through
there without any problem whatsoever
there were reports that the ukrainians
had repelled that advance but we're not
really sure about that there were so
many places that could have crossed uh
crossed into uh into Ukraine from
Belarus it's a 1 000 kilometer long
border and there was a a Bailey Bridge a
temporary Bridge platoon uh um that put
in place along that border as well to
cross the river at one point so that
there is there is really on every front
right now a horrendous situation for
civilians in particular the civilians
many are Sheltering four Subways metros
have been designated to take in people
who want to shelter there's a coded
system on the air raid sirens now but we
haven't had Air Raids for at least
nearly two hours now in the capital
that's not to say there aren't raids
going on elsewhere but here right now
there is a real tension building about
government buildings about whether or
not they'll be they'll be attacked uh by
Special Forces troops and and also about
the city center itself but this does
have the Hallmarks of an attempt for
regime change for with minimal damage to
the capital that could be a plan of the
Russians okay Andrew many thanks Andrew
Simmons there talking to us our
correspondent out of the Ukrainian
Capital Kiev let's bring in Alexander
Bella nutza he is the Ukrainian
ambassador to Kuwait he joins us on
Skype from Q8 City Mr Ambassador welcome
to the NewsHour uh is your country about
to completely fall to Russia
good evening sir can you hear me yes we
can so loud and clear
thank you very much for having me here
tonight sir we will never fall We Will
Never Surrender whatever it takes
we may not be winning at this time but
we're strong enough to resist in any
possible way we have a support of our
partners International Friends allies
and will be strong enough to fight more
I will definitely not be repeating the
data chronological data that you have
shown this
um this video report report
before I uh turned in but I really need
to to say that Ukraine is working at all
possible layers at all possible levels
should it be
I'm Gonna Be Alone
diplomatically economically we are fully
fledged Russia did invade Ukraine Russia
did used innumerable uh missiles and
bombs that been reigning on innocent
people on the innocent population but we
still feel that we are strong enough to
resist uh I will allow myself to tell
you how I spent this day which started
five in the morning locally I had a very
early meeting with my colleagues at the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs of Kuwait
who definitely expressed all their
support and and solidarity with us uh 31
years ago in 1990 Kuwait has been
invaded by Iraq and so they feel exactly
what we are feeling now what we are
suffering now what pain do we have at
this very moment so this solidarity this
similarity we call it black Thursday
black Thursday was in 1990 when Kuwait
was invaded black Thursday is today when
Ukraine is in but Mr Ambassador just let
me just let me stop you there for a
second please sir solidarity and
similarity and diplomacy and political
power and sanctions those are of course
warm words they are an understandable
concept diplomacy doesn't stop bullets
it doesn't stop aircraft carriers it
doesn't stop the Navy it doesn't stop
the helicopters it doesn't stop Russian
Ground Forces diplomacy never has it
never will diplomacy at the moment isn't
dead but it is icy cold you must admit
that
yes correct sir you're absolutely right
you're absolutely right and here I may
not be very diplomatic to say that we
are asking for help we are crying for
help at all the levels and even in my
conversations today here at the Ministry
of Foreign Affairs at the highest level
and we had around 20 ambassadors from G7
from a European Union UK that came to
the Embassy of Ukraine to support and
show solidarity who are actually helping
us with anything that we need uh
Weaponry defense uh techniques uh
microfinance humanitarian Aid and
definitely I also expressed my strong
feelings and requests that if Kuwait can
help me in any way possible and so they
definitely there will be some decision
and we do expect that uh Kuwaiti people
will definitely support us you're
absolutely right sir I will be very uh
asking very very
um strongly to visualize my picture
because that picture actually shows what
was the carpet what was the bombing what
was the shelling what was the reigning
of the bombs on the territory of Ukraine
and at the same time we have a number of
the fronts and it's not only one or two
or three or four sides of the Ukrainian
borders it's actually from all over the
sides and we are still strong enough to
stand so I am very thankful for you to
emphasize that that we do need more than
words and welcoming remarks and that's
what I'm saying and I'm crying today
please assist us as much as we can
because we need to support ourselves
today it's not only about Ukraine it's
about Europe and it's about every single
life
understood thank you very much Alexander
bellanza the Ukrainian ambassador to
Kuwait good to get your thoughts at this
very difficult time sir thank you
thank you